[Music]
stubborn fat it's called that for a
reason because it's hard to get rid of
well Total Transformation the sponsors
of this next segment has the solution
let's start with one of their incredible
success stories
I'm Joanne and I've been on Dr Nash's
program for 12 weeks I've lost 35 pounds
and 24 inches and I no longer need a
seatbelt extender when flying Dodge and
Ash it is so great to see you Joanne's
success story incredible please tell us
more about her yeah I am so happy for
Joanne because she really shows what is
going on in the current population with
women in the United States not only did
she have a weight problem but it was a
stubborn weight problem that wasn't
responding and she was collecting so
much of it in and around that midsection
and this is often related to fatty liver
disease which we're going to get into
but by going after the fatty liver she
was able to lose weight fast 35 pounds
in just 30 days alone and 20 pounds in
the first 10 days and she no longer
needs that seat belt extender where
she's she's super excited about so a
fatty liver can impact weight loss yes
and this is something that a lot of
people really don't know they might get
diagnosed with fatty liver but they do
not know that there's no drug or medical
treatment to correct it they don't know
that over 45 percent of the population
including their children are getting hit
with fatty liver and that your weight
loss your fat loss journey is severely
impaired as a direct result of that
fatty liver how is fatty liver affecting
this then it's because only the liver
converts your body fat into the fuel
that your body can burn but when we have
a fatty liver delivers creating fat that
should not be there there's inflammation
attacking the liver and this is causing
liver cell damage which means that the
cells are dying and turning hard this
will now make the liver work like a
clogged toilet so it doesn't matter how
much fat the liver is trying to convert
it just can't convert it wow will diet
and exercise fix this no and that's
another sad thing right so just simply
eating less and moving more isn't going
to fix it just like if I have a clogged
toilet and I put more stuff in the bowl
I'm not going to fix I'm not going to
fix that clog so fatty liver is not a
body fat problem it's a metabolic
problem so normal weight people have
fatty liver so it can't obviously be
just because of extra body fat and
actually a lot of popular diet foods
contribute to the fatty liver problem
this is eye-opening should we go see a
doctor before getting treatment you you
could potentially go to your doctor if
you wanted to discuss it with them but a
standard blood test typically isn't
going to find the fatty liver until it's
really bad they have to do some kind of
advanced testing like an ultrasound or
an MRI and even if the doctor does find
it JC they don't have any treatment they
can do so a lot of times they either
dismiss it or they give people really
generic advice that doesn't work and you
have the answers though I have the
answers it's 100 reversible if we catch
it in time but you're not going to
reverse it by eating less and moving
more every week you come on the show you
bring a special what do you have for us
this week right so maybe fatty liver is
somebody's problem maybe it isn't but
you want to find out that's when you do
the one-on-one evaluation with me that
evaluation is online it is normally 97
but when I go on Las Vegas now I always
want to bring something special so we
have 10 spots available for 9.97 you can
only get them through the website and
you want to do it fast because the spots
just fill up so quickly especially when
we talk about this liver
all right thank you again to Total
Transformation for sponsoring this
segment Las Vegas now we will be